what what where's the putty give it to
me was it me or does it smell like updog
in here what's up doc
nothing much what's up with you walk
tries to do that oh that's brilliant
hey Stanley said jacket made of up dog
I'm on the phone mmm what flavor coffee
is that up dog what's that I don't know
nothing what's up with you know what
does that mean what is what mean that
thing you just says forget it
wait hey is it me or does this place
smell like updog
what's up dog gosh yeah
[Laughter]
nothing how are you doing good how are
you doing
morning Dwight who are you Who am I
I'm Jim we've been working together for
12 years
we're joke Dwight you're not Jim Jim's
not Asian you seriously never noticed
hey hats off to you for not seeing race
all right then Jim uh why don't you tell
me about that sale that you made
yesterday wellington systems sold them
ten cases of 24-pound lighter stock or
were you talking about Creek or Murphy
because I didn't close that one yet but
I'm hoping I've got a voicemail from
Paul Krieger waiting for me please enter
your password you have one no no no no
that is sensitive information only for
employees not Outsiders like cut it out
I'm trying to work you don't work here
you're not Jim Jim I got a set dinner
reservation Grieco 7:30 oh great can't
wait hmm Jim's at the dentist this
morning and Steve is an actor friend of
ours I don't know who you are but you
are not Jim this is Jim
how do how did not again
boomba cyclops five years ago corporate
said we had to start a recycling program
for Earth Day so Dwight took the lead on
that and introduced us to a very close
friend of his named recyclops happy
Earth Day everyone
I'm recycle ops did you know that an old
milk carton can be sawed in half and
used as a planter the next year you
really stepped things up who has put a
number seven plastic in a number four
bin a year after that recyclops really
began to take shape where cyclops
will drown you in your over watered
lawns then tragedy struck recycle ops
when his fictional planet was attacked
by some other fictitious thing I can't
remember which Cyclops will have his
revenge I think this was also the year
that he renounced the Earth Day and
vowed to destroy the planet he once
loved
oh my god you guys look it's recycle
recycle out today yes the thing I like
most about recyclops is that he's
creating a different world for our child
a world where you truly can be anything
you want god bless you were Cyclops and
your cold robot heart
last week I give a fire safety talk and
nobody paid any attention it's my own
fault for using PowerPoint PowerPoint is
boring people learn in lots of different
ways but experience is the best teacher
today smoking is gonna save lives
I said I wouldn't smell anything smokey
did you bring your jerky in again oh my
god oh my god
fire Oh fire oh my goodness what's the
procedure what do we do people oh how
did that happen out in the hall no we
don't know that the smoke could be
coming through an air dome I god okay
it's happening everybody stay calm
there's a shoe everyone what's the
procedure calm down no no Michael no
touch the handle if it's hot there could
be a fire in the hallway
where's warm me here's the door
check that one out how's the handle
woman can I wait go go go thanks let me
replace Phyllis people human lives
however can this was hot - okay we're
trapped everyone for himself
[Music]
we've already tried that
[Music]
[Music]
use the surge of fear and adrenaline to
sharpen your decision-making okay I am
NOT dying
[Music]
[Applause]
attention employees of Dunder Mifflin
this has been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation what fire not real
this was merely a training exercise so
what have we learned
oh come on it's not real
no no no not like daily
Stanley you will not die Stanley Stanley
muraki's Brendan you are black satellite
I want to give him mouth-to-mouth her no
don't give him mouth-to-mouth for this
swallows hug
you